ご視聴ありがとうございました
少ねえな。さて、何言うて?
凄いわね、今日の豊臣くん。
なに?あれはトンバだけですよ。
リーチ!
ローピンかチーピンを引けば、なんやお三色転廃だ。
親リーか。リャンスは危険だ。
金持ち喧嘩せず、回そう。
うぅ、来ちゃった。
うりゃっ!
師匠!
すっときらなんだら、高めが出てましたやん。
すーわんとりゃんそうが通ったらのお話ね。
あ、出雲!
おれ、親の町はウッパーわんやったやん。
やっぱりどっちも通ってましたやんか。
結果論さ
まあ 安い安い 正解だったね
よーし来た これでダメ押しだ
まだ六順目だし
4 10 ドラドラ9600
師匠 21
手が悪ぅ
ううう
よっしゃぁ!
ツモ3000!
6000!
ズラァー!
ラ!
チッジ!
ギャ!
ツモ
6!
ラ!
ロコ!
スモ
8000!
ズルブル ズジャァ!
ママサン お水くらはい
はい
どうも
おやすみなさい
インスタントにしては結構イケマンなこれ
なんで俺はトップ取れないんだ
いつもトンバは俺にいいハイが来るんだ
今日だってそうだ
難入の時には48000点もあっただろうが
そりゃ分かってますで師匠
問題は何一曲目の親のリーチですやん
リーチ
この時師匠は手の内に一枚しかない現物の数層を切ってベタ折りしあった
それはもう、トップマイク引きは当然の移りだよな。
でも結局その後は。
よし!リーズマー!
ロン9600!
ツボ3600!
ロン7000!
ツボ6000!
ロン6000!
ツボ8000!
違う!
もういい、予測がまずくなる。
やめまへん!
すべてはあのすうそぎりが師匠の敗因だったんや!
エーデッカ師匠、勝負注文はここぞという時に前向きにならなあかんのですわ。わかりますか?
前向き?
そうでんがな。例えば、かの関ヶ原。すでに東軍の勝ち戦が決まったその時。
戦場に取り残された西軍薩摩の軍勢約2000は、チェスト!
キャスター!
どうやら我が西軍の負けのごたる。どうせ退却するなら、さすまっぽの小暦は見せるでご安堂!
押し寄せてくる数万もの東軍に対して、彼らは合戦史上類のない前方退却!
つまり、敵のいる方に向かって退却した!
東軍の総大将、徳川家康のすぐ目の前を駆け抜け、とうとう逃げ切ることができたということですわ!
あっぱれ、一気通貫だっぺ!
もう一つの例え話や
師匠が落題確定の画学生だと考えとくなはれ
はい
どうせ落題が決まっとるなら
師匠はどっちのモデルを描くやろか
前向きヌードか
それとも後ろ向きヌードかと聞いてまんのや
前向き
そうでっしゃろ
男はやっぱり前向きだぜ
マージャンも叱りや。どうせ師匠はラスを引くんや。降りて引くラスより、前向きのラス引かなあかんのや。
おお!
万日ドカーッと玉砕して、箱下十万点になったかで、所詮ラスはラスですぜ。
んだよな。
師匠、分かってもらえたやろうか。
よく分かったぜ。
ところで、どうせラスを引く。今、確かそう言ったよな、おめえ。
え?ご、ご、ご、ご、ご回線といてください、師匠。
わ、岩田だ。
さ、この事実を。
そうか。お前の気持ちはよーくわかった。両手で輪っか作れ。
な、何しますのや?
エンガチョッキーッタ!
え?
出てけー!
し、師匠!
エース。
ぎ、きたな。
いかんなぁ、弟子を大切にせにゃ。
かいそうじゃん。
ほれ、仲直りするだよ。
師匠!
あいつ泣いてたぜ。
かしーやー!
わ、わかったよ。
お前、今から俺の前向きの討ち筋、とくと見とけ。
ええでか。前向きっすよ。
待ってるって。前向き。それはすなわち、がめることなり。
理事だぺ。
しまったー。パワー1切り遅れた。
どうせウーピンもサンゾーも切り遅れてますやん。
ノアにぃ!
な、なんでもあらしばへん。一人ごとです。どうぞ続けとくな、ハレー。
がめり正解!
おい、スーワン切れば単品三色転廃。スーワン通ると思うか?
こういうときは、自分に都合よく読まなあきまへんで!
やっさんのリーチは、きっとこのあんこうになった!
ズバリ、ギャングーピンや!
よしゲーイ!
ローン、リーチピンフダンベー!
リーチ!
降りるだ。
リャンピンチーして三式目の形式転廃か。
だが、パーソが通るか。
チー!
エレアイテッケイセン狙いだ!
ドカーン!リーチチャンタ三色、マンガーン!
今夜のトヨトミはピッチが早ぇなぁ。
師匠、まだあと1000点残ってますぜ。
たとえぶっ飛んでも、姿勢が前向きやったら手はきますよ!
そっか?
ホントだ!いい敗勢だぜ!
やろう。
パーン!
チー!
つまった!
ランホンイズチャット!
よっしゃー!
レンホンインペコ!
ピーチキートイ!
ピークドラドラ!
太陽ドラッサン!
じゅんちゃんジャンペコ!
師匠!前向き大成功!
オーラスでトップ目ですやんか!
うぇーし!こっからが肝心だぜ!
最後まで自力でトップとるぞ!
ホっぽー!
ポンだ!
やぁれ、ここは、強気の入って!
完ぞっ!
前向きっすねぇ!師匠!
あったぼうよー!
よーし、3ピン、あるこったぞ!
ハックポン!
これも、完ぞい!
ぞおぉ!いいき!
カーン カーン カーン
うっしゃー トイトイ三貫通 白ドラさん伝配
バスがドスナー
バステックのカーンだよ
シュシャー
スー貫通
残念だったなトヨトミ
トンカンだ
これで流れだな
数貫通してるときは流れないんだよ
バカ言うなトヨトミ
もう積もるリンシャン杯がないんだぜ
でもよシンタロウ
俺は豊臣の言ってることの方が正しいような気がするけど
俺もこの場合、流れねえと思うぜ
この曲を上がるのは豊臣じゃねえんだ
奴より先に俺が数あんこで上がってやるぜ
そうかい、分かったよ
それじゃ遠慮なく、このドラヒョウジ杯を積もらせてもらうぜ
うそー!
おお、いいわん、ツモ!
おーいるかこんな早い
ツモサンアンコウドラハチ逆転トップ
へーゆうべはそんなことがあったの
前向きが裏目に出ちゃった
でもねトヨトミ君
一人が四つ勘してたらルール上五つ目の勘はできないのよ
知ってた?
え?ま、まじ?
ほいほい
あらおろひれはれ
デュークは言った
俺の後ろに立つな
ミオちゃんは言った
後ろの正面誰
グラマンのパイロットは言った
ゼロを後ろにつかせるな
トヨタミは思った
たまには後ろ向きのモデルも選んでみよう
チャース
ごきげんようママさん
あらいらっしゃい
アキナちゃんも来てくれたのね
ママさんどうしたの
ママさんどうしちゃったのこいつら
魂が抜けてるよ
そうなのよ実はさっき
そいつらはこの俺が叩きのめしてやる
なに
ああ、退屈だな
トヨトミは何やってんだ
ママさん、奴が来るのはいつ?
トヨトミ君は今日は夕方からよ
昼間は大学の講義があるんですって
ママさん、後期の試験は終わったのに
講義なんかあるわけないでしょ
あら、そうなの?
うま
入れるか?
ええ、ちょうどこちら、すぐ入れます
そうかい、よいしょっと、よろしくお願いします
あんた、まあ、ええれ、太ってる
かもかも
あの男、何かで見たことあるわ
ああ、そういえば確か
おらが親だな
な えっ
本田 リーチ
えっ
おっと強い兄者 安倍切るのは強いとは言わねえんだよ
何が安倍だ入り目だよとっさー えっ
いやー おめーも甘いとこ切り合って
おら、ちゃんと読んでるだよ。おめえの町は老朽岩だっぺ。おら、あんこにしてるだよ。
老安、今、とったろが。よく見てろ、このタコ。
何言ってた。おらにインパチ振って泣くのは、慎太郎だよ。
おら、おら、引けってばよ。
さあ、出しやがれ、このタコデブ。
ドラ旅
バイマニスっぺ ドラ短期待ちだ
太っちょのリャンピングは一回り早えな
アンダーアーピーで一発だってよ
よし、ツモドライチ
フリッテル
しかもツモドライチだけ
なんちゅうタコあがりだべ
あんたらの街をすべて止めたらこうなっただけさ
リーチ
おっと、またペンチーワンのひっかけかい
甘い甘い
トイトイが好きだな
あんたパワーワンとチュンのサブか
兄さん、ダマでピンフリッツを貼ってても高めの数案は出さないぜ。
俺たちの肺が完全に読まれてる。
一点読みの太っちょ?
そう、通称一点読みの太っちょ。最近現れたジャンゴロよ。
ものすごく読みの感が冴えてて、絶対に振り込まないの。
このままじゃうちのお客さんみな殺しにされちゃうわ
わかりましたママさん
この男トヨトミがやつをへこましてみせましょう
一緒に頑張ろうね
安心しなママさん俺一人で十分さ
アキナちゃんと私でなんとかしましょう
が、頑張ってみます
頑張ろう二人で
あのね
トヨトミ君はタコでも茹でてて
あ、ぼ、僕も入ります!
おぉ、ママさん率いる女性コンビの登場かい。
悪いな!俺もいるぜ!
うん。
リーチ!
やったー!ドラが飛びつった!
ハネマンまであるぞ!
あら、スジ!
ドン!リーチ一発!イーペイとウラドラ一行!
行こう!
やっぱ、よくばらし現物のEP切っときゃよかった!
こんな見え見えのひっかけに乗っちまうとは、随分とまたお粗末なメンバーもいたもんよ。
それはともかく、失礼ママさん、頭はねた。
何がおかしい?
お客さん、後から倒してカッコつけたつもりらしいが、この店はダブルオンありなんだぜ。
だぜそうかそれじゃあお前はマンガンと本人を振り込んだというわけだな ずがっ
me 自分で何ボケツ掘ってんのよちょいと失礼するぜ
ええええええ もしや
ああああああ いいってちゃんっ
肝を養うために、あんた、薬をやってたのか?
チッ、見られたか?
そんな危ない人は、店から出てってもらいます!
もちろん、今までの勝ち分はチャラね!
はい、さよなら、お巡りさん!
ちゃう、やだ、エッチ!
待てって、貴様、何を言っとるんだ!
それは、ただのブドウ糖だ!
何だ、ブドウ糖!
え?
あら、本当、甘い。
当たり前だ。
ブドウ糖は、単なる砂糖の成分。
俺はな、栄養剤によって、自分の肝を養ってるだけよ。
あきくん
なるほど、それでそんなにデブるのか
冴えてきた冴えてきたぞ
リーチ、さすがの一点読みの太っちょでも、これは嫁だよよ
六級腕町か、いい町だな
だが俺が相手じゃなかったらの話だ
うっそー、妻
よくもまあ読み切られてるローアン積もったね
ビーチをかけたら読まれる
ここはダマデ
ダマデも俺にはわかるよ
カンリャンゾウだろ
なんでわかるの
ツモ
ハネマーン
まさかこんな街は読めないでしょ
シャボだって読めるさ
ウーアンとパストを待ちだ
見え見えでバカみたい
ツボ
恥ずかしいけどおやばい
まずい
この娘の親は早く流さないと
チ
ポン
よしツボ
ゴミの一本は六本四本
トミ
いかん
この俺としたことが2万点以上も沈んで3位だ
今度は攻撃に出るぞ
早くもウーパーピンでマンガン張ってるな
おっとよしウーピン完
続いてパーピンも完
リーチ
その手配ならローチーピンを落とすしかあるまい
ん?
リーチ!
何?
馬鹿だ!
ローン!
リーチ一発、タイヤをチートイ!
ドラドラドラドラ!
ドラドラドラドラドラドラドラドラドラドラドラドラ!
どうやら、トンの一曲でぶっ飛びのようですな。
貴様にだけは言われたくねえ。
モーハンちゃんだ!
さっそくリーチ!
ペンチーピンだろ?
やだ!ズバリ!一発ツモっておやまーん!
そうだろ!そうだろ!
あなたの読み通りツモ!
そうだろ!
ズバリ!ツモ!
フォクシック・ソウマチ・ミッキー!
あなたの読みにはかなわないわ!
いつも、逆満!
飛び。
一点読みの太っちょとやら、あんたの負けだ!
な、なんだと?
なんで貴様にまでそんなこと言われなきゃならんのだ!
同点の飛びでも俺はちーちゃ。
あんたはシャーケ。つまり、頭ラスはあんたなんだよ!
やったわ
とどめはやっぱり豊臣くんね
町を読んでも仕方ねえ
もう相手の川なんざ見ねえぜ
ただ前進あるのみ
よーし
出た出た高め
メンホン一通 いいぺいこ 羽目
ラスト
アンさん
いくらなんでもこれは無茶でんがな
ちっと相手の町を読むだよ
ほれ、これが筋っつうもんだよ。
はいはい、三択太っちょさん、またまたぶっ飛び。
人生、浮き沈みはつきものね。
あんたが沈めたんでしょうが、あんたが。
浮いて沈んで、沈んで浮いて、
とがくこの世は波まかせ、
ナミにまかせたつもりでも あしたのみなとがきにかかる
このつぎは あのつかんぽのはなにまつわる ちょっとせつないこいのおはなしです
バレンタインデーにケンジンくんがであった すてきなおんなのこ
じかい バレンタインはつかんぽのかおり あきなトライアングル
きっとみてね ねむっちゃいや
エンディング
お疲れ様でした
ここは三面町どころ
行くぞカンキャン
おしむそごの席がはだ
スモーリーゴーマーケングーにやりぬいて
勝手飲み越すビールがうまい
スカット
おたかわいのちがけ
チコンショー チコンショー
カネタ カネタ
ハムザイノ